well beyond the useful debate Intrigue
including a jocking for time the best
one-liners as Bill just mentioned
Republicans hope that what happens
tonight is actually going to set them on
a course to win next year not buy a hair
but by a huge margin now things are
looking really horrid for Democrats
right now gas prices skyrocketing again
the average getting close to four
dollars a gallon again and it's over six
dollars in places like California did
you see the consumer confidence numbers
today they're cratering the border is an
invited Invasion and we warned about it
it's only getting worse and the most
sickening disregard for human life is on
display across Urban America
Everybody Must Eat Everybody Must Eat
[Music]
yeah
oh my God
apparently they're eating iPhones
well Trump predicted America would fall
apart if Biden won and he's pretty much
been right hasn't he been and as a
result he looks like he'll be very hard
to stop
but no matter who the nominee is
showcasing our candidates tonight asking
them tough questions it shows the GOP
strength and its depth especially when
compared to the decrepit party of Joe
Biden we know that he's you know not
going to have any real No Holds Barred
presser anytime between now and November
it's just not going to happen he's not
capable of it but right now Republicans
look simply don't have enough power to
make things better as bad as we know
Biden is and Republicans are not going
to have enough power to make things
better unless they can grow their
coalition
now let's face it the wrong likely to
persuade upper class social liberals to
work with them or trust them on things
like you know maybe rubber stamping the
pentagon's budget that's about all
they'll agree on so that leaves Working
Class People from across the country a
multi-ethnic coalition
and from time to time you know we've
seen Democrats they try to go through
the motions with Working Class People
but it's all pretend
it doesn't mean anything the fact is
everything Democrats are doing is
undermining the buying power the parent
power and the safety of working-class
Voters and boy do they feel it it's
harder and harder to get by they still
work a job because like you know most
people you can't retire 100 because uh
we need to work you know groceries are a
lot more now am I supposed to work until
I'm 70 80 years old the economy is not
good inflation is horrible kids can't
even go to the park and play without
them shooting okay stand in front of a
restaurant and talk to your friend
without losing your life and that's
where I put my grass
Trump knows their anxiety and the fear
it's real it can't be dismissed or spun
away as much as the White House tries to
do this this is partly why Trump's going
to Michigan to address the Auto Workers
of course Biden failed to mention
yesterday how much worse off the average
michigander is under his leadership real
wages in Michigan are down the state
ranks 37th now on the real median
household income scale it dropped by the
way from 32. nice going
but the whole GOP they also have to get
at least in their mind to Michigan
and frankly this is a test run at the
debate tonight and for the GOP members
of Congress fighting over the budget
they have to understand the importance
of bringing working-class voters into
this party everything else it's a waste
of time
now some have suggested that they follow
more of an establishment friendly
approach maybe folks like Mitt Romney or
Liz Cheney can teach them a thing or two
apparently Nikki Haley is getting some
real attention from the old guard and a
lot of big donors
well they hate Trump we know that and
they don't much like populism but even
if you assume that there are a bunch of
Voters out there who want more trade
with China liberalized immigration and
war with Russia those voters are already
on Biden's side
the Republicans cannot out establishment
the Democrats remember McCain tried that
in 2008 Romney tried it in 2012. it
didn't work then and it will not work
now
Republicans have to be the party of
populism because they certainly aren't
going to be the party of Wall Street or
Silicon Valley not going to be the party
of Hollywood
there aren't going to be any more
pro-ukraine either than Biden is there
aren't going to be any more pro-china
than buying they are going to be more
pro-open borders in Biden
those Avenues are closed and the only
lane open is toward the working class
that's the backbone of our economy our
traditions and our patriotic Spirit
remember that they along with Urban
voters are being shafted by the D.C una
party
and so we got to reach out to them hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else